[Music]
thank you
the Star Wars holiday special wait we're
in the action already where's my opening
crawl I know it's a bit hit and miss
with modern Star Wars but this is 1978
for crying out loud how am I supposed to
know when this is happening or how far
far away that's it I'm turning back
I know your family's waiting
I know it's an important day look if you
have to have Han restate whatever Chewie
is saying in a contrived way just so
that we understand what's going on why
not just give us Wookie subtitles it's
almost like making an entire TV special
based on creatures that can only
communicate through Grunts and moans
wasn't a great idea also they're being
chased by the enemy and in danger of
being shot down and still Chewie's only
concern seems to be that he'll be home
later than planned I know Han can be a
dick Chewie but currently he's trying to
save both of your asses oh so now you
decide to hit us with the opening tech
scroll well now you get a sin for being
late and reading also Star Wars was an
immediate huge hit huge like really huge
so I'm just stunned that they cheaped
out so hard on this TV special for
minute one like you couldn't even be
bothered to use the right font and
coloring for the titles
[Music]
having a Johnny Gilbert ask announcer
for your Star Wars holiday special but
not actually having Johnny Gilbert
r2d2s R2D2 wait we've just listed all
the actual actors but now we're listing
R2D2 as R2D2 he's R2D2 real now are they
a part of the Actors Guild what the [ __ ]
happened to Kenny Baker his son lumpy
you have a character named [ __ ]
Chewbacca and the best you can come up
with for a son's name is Lumpy they
didn't even want any one of the Seven
Dwarves lumpy you gave Chewbacca's kid a
name that wasn't even seven dwarves
Worthy
Star Wars story I give all the sins back
if the next picture was of the Star Wars
kitchen sink
kids also while I'm sure in a world of
space travel and the vehicles that come
with it toys would be made but it does
still give the impression that lumpy is
playing with a Star Wars toy in a Star
Wars special and therefore he deserves
an order of Star Wars sins
well we have no clue what itchy is
actually saying to lumpy I'm gonna
assume it's something along the lines of
no you will not get to play with the sex
toy Art Carney brings me later and then
lumpy says who's our Carney and then
itchy says get off my lawn
foreign
[Music]
are they angry are they sad are they mad
does she want the kid to get in the
trash can now what the [ __ ] is he doing
I get that somebody wanted to show off
this map painting of kashyyk from above
but did it have to come with the
unnecessary dangerous Balancing Act ah
yes magical kashyyk come for the wookies
stay for the IKEA furniture I'm sure we
can all agree that the only thing A New
Hope was missing was an Olympic routine
performed by a posse of miniature
holographic spandex grabats also we were
supposed to get a Wookie Planet instead
of ewoks in Return of the Jedi based on
what I'm seeing here I'm starting to
really like that we got Ewoks this
special is making me appreciate [ __ ]
Ewoks this text is in English is clearly
being displayed on a personal computer
from the 70s and we're expected to
believe this is just the [ __ ] Norm on
kashyyk none of which is impossible but
it's insane that someone took the time
to create this Arena of utter [ __ ]
but not a believable living space for
this family of Wookies and while we've
circled back to it this table and
everything it stands for
oh I know this one kiss hug kiss hug hug
hug kiss hug hug kiss kiss hug hug kiss
hug great well then glad we cleared that
one up
wait they could just drop it on Luke
whatever the [ __ ] they want why is that
a thing that's allowed what if he's uh
well liberating some Rebels or
polishing his kyber crystals or getting
in touch with his dark side I wouldn't
worry about Chewbacca I know him and he
hasn't missed a life day yet right
Luke's words of wisdom continue in this
vein and boil down to the idea that
Chewbacca never missing a life day so
far will guarantee he won't miss this
one and that there's no chance that he's
been shot down lightsaber to return into
a wooky skin rug come on Mama let's see
a little smile after Luke saw this smile
he died mysteriously seven days later
but not before he attended his nephew's
birthday party to give him a model train
but when the box was open there was a
dead cat in it we talk about that
incident even less than the Star Wars
holiday special
like nobody's perfect and other than a
token appearance at the end of the
special that is all we'll get from Mark
Hamill in the Star Wars holiday special
I know Christmas is about more than the
presents but this kind of feels like
your parents promising to buy you that
Lego Millennium Falcon only to find out
they totally misunderstood what a
Millennium Falcon and a Lego is so you
end up with a thousand tiny plastic
Birds of Prey a full 30 seconds of Mala
typing and bringing up various screens
guys it's totally cool if you want to
make this a 30 minute thing no one was
asking you to pad the runtime to over 90
minutes in fact no one was asking for
this at all
an Imperial Guard
I suppose you want to see my
identification imagine having Art Carney
agree to appear in your special and then
having him do this scene you had art
[ __ ] Carney and you blew it
got a love screen wait Mala dialed in
minutes ago why is this only just
ringing now why would it let a customer
peek at the shop and then wait so long
to alert the shopkeeper also is this
monitor moving around the shop because
when Mala dialed in it was looking over
here but now Trader Dan is addressing it
as if it's on the opposite side of the
room
Shaggy carpet you ordered will arrive at
your home I'm assuming this was
broadcast in England at some point so a
Shaggy carpet is a very interesting code
word to describe Chewbacca to his wife I
want the rebels located and identified
yay Vader's here
We're not gonna see him again are we
today
is the surprise that we're finally going
to be treated to something enjoyable to
watch or is it yet another baffling
facet of this very confusing variety
show that's currently wearing a barely
recognizable Star Wars skin suit
so we're literally gonna see every step
of this cooking show the ingredients and
all man book a Boba Fett really isn't
looking so bad now is it guess what I
forgot how to make a TV special the
script my [ __ ] marbles
one thing I'm 100 sure of is no one is
having fun currently also we're almost a
third of the way through this special
and 98 of it has been spent on
Chewbacca's family Sans Chewbacca who
are characters we've never [ __ ] seen
before who thought a Star Wars holiday
special without the majority of it being
based around the popular Star Wars
characters was a good idea also also
imagine having Harvey Corman agree to
appear in your special and then having
him do this scene you had Harvey [ __ ]
Corman and you blew it out of the frying
opinions
would come out of hyperspace in the
middle of an imperial Convoy well
shouldn't the [ __ ] ship tell you that
kind of [ __ ] up faster than light
navigation system doesn't tell you
what's at the place you're arriving at
what if you arrived inside another ship
due to suspected activity on the kazuk
planet kazuk what the [ __ ] is kazuk am I
gonna have to keep Wikipedia up this
entire damn time
oh so they called kashyyk kazuk just for
this special man they really didn't give
a sh did they not so fast what does an
old friend get nothing says healthy
long-lasting relationship between old
buddies quite like forcing one person to
give physical affection to the other in
order to receive a gift the 70s were
packed with these amazing examples of
love if you know where to look we will
now spend 40 seconds watching lumpy go
to his room Columbus a present and seem
Overjoyed by it only we haven't got a
[ __ ] clue what it is or why we should
give a sh I am begging for someone to
tell me what's going on here the
unbuttoning of our Kearney shirt is so
pronounced I'm beginning to think he put
this demand in as part of his contract
kind of how to explain it's a
wow you know what I mean no no I do not
know what you mean do you I swear this
movie is like if the Green Knight had a
baby with a slightly less coherent
version of the Green Knight
[Music]
Star Wars survives this as daihan
Carroll's talents are largely squandered
on this poor imitation of a James Bond
song I want you all to remember that
itchy is watching this very seductive
performance while his daughter-in-law is
preparing life Day dinner and his
grandson is opening toys in the Next
Room which in turn is all being watched
by a family in 1978 expecting a
follow-up to A New Hope as a thank you
for putting up with the low quality of
this video we're going to treat you to a
mid-sinning bonus round this song is
just over three minutes long but manages
to say the word minute well you can
count for yourself
this minute
[Music]
[Music]
this minute
meanwhile Princess Leia and C-3PO are
frantically trying to get their taxes
done you mean they haven't arrived yet
she says there has been no contact yep
each of the characters you know and love
from A New Hope are dragged in Via video
links so they can all be surprised about
exactly the same thing while being
completely unable to help in any way at
all it's as if we're dropping in on each
of them to accept an award they didn't
even know they were nominated for for a
role they didn't even remember they
played Mala are you alone no my
father-in-law is right behind me jerking
off to a simulation but I feel like the
less said about that the better good
afternoon ma'am ma'am [ __ ] ma'am
that's Princess Leia of house Organa
first of her name Queen of the Andals
wait nope that's the other show
ing word for it why don't you no chance
he's a spy or anything no wonder a kid
goes wrong so it's a long walk a little
exercise never hurt anybody preferring a
higher potentiality of getting murdered
over a little extra exercise
premature wikibration
they've got video chatting monitors in
this house but no ringer cams for the
doors I'm all for dramatic pauses and
loaded silences
but this interminable Imperial guarding
goes on for one minute and 10 seconds
interminable I say
will you get on with it this random
Imperial Guard would be excellent at TV
sins I like that someone out there was
like you know what Star Wars is missing
Jefferson's Starship and then someone
else was like that's [ __ ] genius also
this song has a course that includes the
line let's vanish Without a Trace sung
over and over which is exactly what
happened to the Star Wars holiday
special so at least the song was on
point also also this built-in music
video lasts 4 minutes and 10 seconds
here's 410 sins to celebrate its
awfulness also to the fourth be with you
somehow they managed to rip off Darth
Maul's double lightsaber from The
Phantom Menace 20 years before it was
released although I am happy that
there's something in the Star Wars Canon
Now worse than The Phantom Menace they
leave now I guess you're right about all
I can do for now but what did he do he
distracted one of the guards for a few
minutes but then got distracted himself
what was his game plan here so now we're
breaking the fourth wall I get it no one
is enjoying this but do you have to
stare directly into my eyes while we're
both not enjoying it we were awaiting
the return of Captain Han Solo on his
first mate Chewbacca to keep lumpy out
of trouble he sat down with an animated
Adventure featuring Han Solo Chewbacca
R2D2 C3PO Princess Leia Luke and [ __ ]
Boba Fett look this special takes place
maybe a couple of years but likely a
matter of months after a new hope so
maybe someone out there has put together
some cartoon propaganda featuring the
heroes that blew up the Death Star but I
refuse to believe that said cartoon
would include Boba [ __ ] fat or that
it would be appropriate viewing for a
[ __ ] child also if Chewbacca is
famous enough to have a cartoon made of
him and his family's living openly on
kashik or kazonk or whatever I can't
believe these Imperial guards don't
already know this is where Chewbacca
lives
what do you say I'm sure this point has
been raised but honestly how hard would
it be to program R2 to speak or are we
worried that that would make C-3PO
entirely irrelevant I am Boba Fett the
best thing that can be said about this
monstrosity is that it's not the worst
use of Boba Fett in a Star Wars themed
TV show I have made contact with the
rebels and all is proceeding As You Wish
Darth Vader okay let's talk about the
villain's ridiculous plan for a minute
Vader wakes up one morning finds an
imperial Lackey and says you know what
I'm gonna create this magical Talisman
and trick the rebels into thinking it
will grant them invisibility but when
they find it it actually just puts them
to sleep and the genius of this plan is
that it'll allow Boba Fett to gain their
trust by swooping in with the Cure and
they'll never suspect he's working for
us forgive me Lord Vader but that seems
needlessly complicated why not just
create a Talisman of poisoning or
killing or if you don't want them dead
maybe some sort of transport
[Music]
apparently what you're gonna do is wait
till Boba Fett has returned to the ship
given the antidote let everyone have a
lovely cup of tea and only then tell a
[ __ ] soul that he's been working for
Darth Vader why did this take so long is
C-3PO working for Vader what happened I
was wondering the same thing your nose
looks like it's been split in two and
why are your eyes always closed on oh
you are referring to Luke's predicament
carry on then but still animated Han
Solo is [ __ ] terrifying an adult
going into a child's room and coming out
with the room messier than it was when
they went in is a pretty amazing feat in
and of itself this needless decapitation
of this bantha and its subsequent
surgery and or burial is the most
emotional sequence in this TV special
and I'd have skipped it already had I
not already had every nerve deadened
into a confusion comb of what the
fuckitude so clean up your room you're
not my dad that will keep him busy for a
while you're not my husband
[Applause]
now Star Wars is a 70 billion dollar
franchise time now for life on Tatooine
[ __ ] tattoo Wayne even in 1978 we
couldn't get through a peripheral Star
Wars installment without visiting that
Sandy anus of a planet well I am
certainly not going to get rich with
customers like you discount B are holy
[ __ ] imagine having B Arthur agree to
appear in your special and then having
her do this scene you had B [ __ ]
Arthur and you blew it stealing the
uniforms from Star Trek the Next
Generation nine years before it came out
hello at me it's really weird they just
inserted a sketch from The Carol Burnett
showing here and no one noticed
[Music]
credits of this TV special I decided
what you meant was exactly the thing I
needed to hear Twitter I just came in
here for a drink and I found a lot more
apparently the Empire's version of
anti-tattooine propaganda is an
unrequited love story set in a CD bar
and while this truly has been successful
in submitting my lack of desire to visit
that beige ball of [ __ ] this still
feels like a super bizarre angle to take
for an oppressive Galactic regime of
fascists all inhabitants will return to
their homes at once the next five
minutes five minutes will be spent with
acmina as she tries to convince the
locals to go home and eventually
resorting to singing to get the job done
that makes this an eight minute
propaganda video put together by the
Empire eight minutes and a polite
Cabaret is the best they could do with
those eight minutes this next musical
interlude takes on the heady task of
attempting to put words to the famous
Cantina Band song I'll just let the tone
of my voice communicate how successful I
think they were imagine having Michael
Myers agree to appear in your special
and then having him do this scene you
had Michael [ __ ] Myers and you blew
it
message received and obeyed accepting
the nonsense idea that an imperial radio
can be hacked into by a Wookie child in
their life Day present wouldn't this
order have to be accompanied by an
authorization code or something also
does the do-it-yourself transmitter come
pre-loaded with a series of commands
just in case you need to distract
Imperial guards it might be presumptuous
of me to assume the strength of a
wookie's maternal instincts but it is
wild to me the model allows an armed
Stormtrooper to go into her son's room
with his arms and legs still attached
was destroying it really the best idea
there maybe check it out first see if
there's another way to end the distress
signal or even change the signal
foreign
[Music]
also TV special can't even let Han trip
first I mean I guess I shouldn't be
surprised that Mala and Chewie don't
care that lumpy is in the room Mala
didn't bother to tell itchy to go jerk
off with his sex packet somewhere else
earlier is this a report about the
missing Trooper Trader Dan will explain
that after the Imperial guards left the
missing Troopers stole a bunch of food
and ran to the hills and this will be
accepted as an absolute fact never mind
the mystery transmission with falsified
orders that caused the guards to leave
in the first place they just accept Good
Old Trader Dan's word because he has ID
well and the fact that the plot seems to
make everyone exactly as trusting as
they need to be May the force be with
you so Trader Dan swoops it out of
nowhere just in time to answer a call
from the Empire make up some [ __ ]
about the missing Stormtrooper they just
killed and then pieces out Exit Stage
right as if that wasn't the biggest
stroke of Good Fortune since that Death
Star engineer thought I really think
this exhaust room needs a skylight over
candling around extremely flammable
robes the one good thing that could come
out of this is that once they go into
the light they might find and Carol Ann
I'm sure the freelings will be very
thankful also Disney bought Star Wars
for over 4 billion dollars it is indeed
true that at times like this
Otto and I wish that we were more than
just mechanical beings and we're really
alive so that we could share your
feelings with them but doesn't wishing
you were alive mean that you're feeling
something all of you are an important
part of my life pal skip this holiday is
yours and yet Leia will go on to
immediately say how important it is to
stay United against the empire and
essentially usurps the life Day
celebration by bursting into her own
propaganda song set to a day that takes
us through the darkness wait
I know that tune they put words to the
[ __ ] Star Wars theme too no matter
how different we appear we're all the
same in our struggle against the powers
of evil and darkness wow there is
literally no truth in that statement
that's kind of impressive this is just
reminding me of that fraternity paddle
scene in animal house and now I can't
think about anything else and no sir I
really do not want another to wrap up
this cacophony of incredulity we get
four minutes of clips from A New Hope
presumably because they had no idea how
to end this thing or someone had the
presence to know that it was so bad that
it would taint any good will towards the
original movie unless they slapped on a
montage that screams hey hey don't
forget you actually like Star Wars
before this
thank you
what isn't that special you think God
stays in heaven because he too lives in
fear of what he's created
your pain runs deep
what do you know of my pain let us
explore it
together I'm ending all of this
I'm gonna burn it down
row row row your boat gently down the
stream
merrily merrily merrily merrily gently
down the stream oh an Imperial Guard
I suppose you want to see my
identification what
he's trying to spawn
if I got to see him
this is like the apex of the vortex of
joint engineering it's rumored that mm
O'Shaughnessy designed the first one the
guy who uh designed the Golden Gate
Bridge my second favorite civil engineer
behind hands Carl bandel Madison Square
Garden
[Music]
couldn't carrying my wisdom Beyond
I want you to round up every vicious
criminal and Gunslinger in the west I
want wrestlers Cutthroats murderers
bounty hunters Desperados mugs pugs
thugs liquids half wits dimwits if I'd
had the money I could have been living
in a swinging condo instead of with I
better not say anything till I've had my
coffee a [ __ ] and a [ __ ]
[Music]
you see Joe I'm 106 years old been
waiting a long time for this for what
the great beyond